okay hello everyone this is a wolf
language design review
about how we are
setting up our assessment framework
for math expressions and the question of
when is x squared minus 1 considered
equal to X Plus 1 times x minus 1 and 1
is it not
is that a fair summary of what we're
talking about here yes yes that is yeah
right so we've had this assessment
framework for
a couple years but mostly it's kind of
relied on exact matches in like a
multiple choice situation or
sort of unambiguous matching and but
since you know we're kind of very well
positioned to do more complicated stuff
surrounding math right the problem is
that of different levels of math I mean
to a calculus student x squared minus 1
is equal to x minus 1 times X plus one
but to an algebra student they're not
supposed to be considered equal yes
that's right that's right so if we're
just calling it math we need to support
all those cases yep right okay
um so yeah so from the I have this demo
notebook that's kind of working at a
very high level and then we can get into
the weeds as we move on
um if that works so you know you can do
some like question object and you can
you know put the answer in here and we
support things like tolerance where just
the total difference between the answer
has has some acceptable Tolerance on it
so so hold on hold on hold on people are
not using slide rules anymore
are they
you know a slide rule right you have to
read off the numbers and you might have
a slight mistake right
uh the only way people are going to have
different things if they're using like a
calculator or something and they didn't
type in as many decimal digits but
otherwise I don't understand how they
would get
11.001 right so maybe they're using a
calculator right so yeah the idea is not
necessarily that the student is solving
these
in Wolfram language it's that that
that's the teachers tool and they're
presenting the notebook and the student
solves it how they solve it and you
might have a question but I'm I'm
disputing
for an algebraic case
that numerical tolerance makes a lot of
sense
by the time it's algebra they're
probably not doing approximate numbers
okay well I mean if if the coefficients
here were approximate maybe why would
they ever have that nobody does that do
they I don't maybe it's an engineering
class where they're read from some table
in some book right
um all right okay
because I think
yeah okay fair enough okay
for example do we have unit matching do
we know you know if somebody has a same
type of thing if they say Jewels versus
they say kilograms meters yeah that's
been that's been built in for a while
yeah
or do we do we have the same kind of
things I can imagine
um
okay but let me make a comment about
that it's the same deal
to some people jewels and
and um
well it doesn't matter you don't need to
write it out kilogram meters per second
squared
okay uh here we can do control equals
right
um
no I'm not sure that's the word hold on
hold on hold on for example kinetic
energy would be Mass yeah it would be
mass times that squared all squared
meters per second all squared okay uh
I can't mess into it
I think you can just click here just
click it
I'm not allowed to you accept it if you
can't yeah
can you do that I'll try it yep okay all
right ow okay unable to that's strange
I don't know
with the search points what the hell is
search points quantity here you've got
you've got weird error messages there
with near us well I mean this oh
because I did
okay search radius
bug that's a bug
rolled out
got it
why do you have to do a tolerance for a
quantity I don't think you should this
is about this is definitely a bug in the
quantity Center you shouldn't need to do
intolerance but it accepts it and it
does sure you should be able to do a
tolerance that is a pure numerical
tolerance which will be the numerical
coefficients you get what I'm saying
just like it is in the algebra case
you're not saying
there we go okay um
okay
we'll put in a five though put in a five
because the quantity is the the as the
thing you are assessing to
okay that just happens yeah yeah uh oh I
guess there yeah they're equivalent
yeah all right um okay but but hold on
hold on hold on stop for a second okay
whatever framework we're gonna give for
for the equivalent of algebraic
expressions we've also got that for unit
Expressions we've also got a super unit
expressions
that's what I'm saying
for some classes Jewels are the same as
that kilograms meter squared blah blah
blah they are not yes
right so yeah what we've had for a while
is a quantity comparison method with an
assessment function which assumes that
you want to automatically convert I know
I'm saying that's probably a case where
we don't want that right right we also
have like uh that where it could just be
like a held expression is a comparison
method that we have that okay yeah fine
but I think that's too detailed I'm just
saying I'm just flagging this is another
thing but let's keep going on the um
all right so with So within math so you
know uh what we're looking at today is
you know you have your answer key and
then you have math expression just what
we have it named right now that we can
and then within this we have a method
option
that allows is going to allow all of
this you know uh customization okay and
um so right now we have two primary
methods
match what we've called match and what
we've called equal
we have people from the Wolfram Alpha
math team here
no
it's good yeah
badly maybe I don't know who
uh because because what I'm gonna say is
you know even a communal garden llm now
knows things like what fifth grade math
is about yes I we can we can talk about
llms uh
if we want I have that over an example
that we can get to later okay
um
right so so that we have matched which
eventually feeds into magic queue
and we have equal which eventually feeds
into you know double equal
um okay and you know that there's those
are you know the equality of the
unevaluated expression or match Q of the
evaluated expression by default
unevaluated uh we have sub options that
let you control that evaluation
and you can customize it on and on yeah
the there's some options here that get
into the weeds but we've tried to make
the default very sensible
uh by default when you're working in the
match method it's unevaluated everything
is either inactivated or held right
um so you know here's an example okay
can you give me a big picture of of the
my x squared minus one example how do we
deal with that
right so uh if you have you realize I'll
just do assessment function
um of x squared minus one yeah
x squared minus one
right
um so
so you know that's always that's by
default going to be considered math
right we have some heuristics that look
at it and say math okay so so we do end
up on this framework automatically and
by default right now and this is
something that we want to discuss
um
yeah it's gonna pass is it okay that's
right
um it's gonna okay so now put an
expander copy down no no no leave that
leave that leave that copy it down put
an expand on the right hand side there
no no not there
okay
um so Chris is this going to match by
default then or is this going to oh yeah
there's going to equal by default but
even equal even the double equal thing
absurd you know X double equal y if one
polynomial is expanded one is factored
yeah well it doesn't really cool right
right so that that's what's Happening
Here is it's getting passed to something
like this and that's not
determining that it's equal so it's
giving incorrect here
um right and there's two main sub
options that we've introduced what we've
called inactive pattern which isn't the
best most beautiful name but it's
it tells you what it does and something
we call Transformations
um so inactive pattern lets you control
what evaluates and doesn't basically
whatever you put here gets passed into
the second argument of inactivate
um so it's heads
I know but people on the live stream
might not
um so you can you can very much control
the the evaluation so you know maybe the
only thing you don't want to allow to
evaluate is the multiplication between
these terms but the pluses where the
minus signs are you can allow or you
know yes so it it works out um so you
can reorder terms here but you can't
expand terms that sort of thing and
it'll be correct
um
right here's another one where
we've inactivated power so you know the
division
yeah it evaluates and right so
um and then the second main option here
is Transformations and these get applied
in the case of equal they get wrapped
around the entire equality
right so you have you know
transformation one so it's F of one
equals equals F of two basically
no it's f of x equals C equals y of you
know which is important
because even if you have like the factor
polynomial expanded one if you just
simplify on both sides it might not end
up in the same place
but if you just simplify around the
equation it's gonna it's gonna really
find it yes
yes uh yeah yeah uh yeah Danny Finn
pointed out a great example to us early
on of that exact use case so we did we
decided that the transformations in this
case apply around the entire quality in
the case of the match method the
Transformations are applied to each half
independently
um so
you know the Transformations for the
equal case are much easier to come up
with because they don't have to like
operate through a hold generally
um
uh so you can you can use like expands
and fly
um in the match case
uh you know you can do things like
replace and that works just again yep
but we're also we've also come up with
some named ones that we haven't
documented yet but we think this idea of
the shorthand name transformation yeah I
agree okay so let's get to the end of
the agenda let's come back to this what
what's the next thing you're going to
talk about here okay
um uh here's an example of one that came
out of chat GPT
um so we can keep going into sort of
lower level details we'll get into that
no I think I'm understanding that you
have
a concept here of equal or match exactly
why isn't it called same Q versus equal
well it's not passing the same to you
it's passing to match Q we want to we we
can support things like blanks
you know you can do a hold of X plus
blank
why the hell would you want that for
math
I mean you know you know you don't
necessarily want imagine an indefinite
integral where there's a constant and
you don't necessarily need to use the
Big C you can use anything right yeah
no you can't use anything because you
could put an X in there and you would
have the wrong answer well well maybe
maybe you have a panel test no no
nobody's gonna do that okay let me ask a
meta question all this stuff have you
look you know talk to the folks like
Bradley here who do math content yes
who'd you talk to we've had multiple
meetings with Bradley and fine yeah
okay okay because the thing you just
said is a non-starter of of plus blank
it's just wrong
you know some kid is going to write plus
sign X I think a sophisticated teacher
could come up with good pattern based
yeah they're never gonna do it if we do
that we want a thing called indefinite
integral
it's just a string name but we've done
the right thing
yeah yeah that totally is the sort of
thing that we're planning on yeah yeah
we don't like because integrals are kind
of complicated because they can have a
constant difference right exactly right
right so yes yes yeah we haven't
specifically talked about an indefinite
integral one but that's the sort of
thing we want to build out
more
uh I I think the blank thing is a
non-starter I think right what do you
think the advantage of same Q versus
match Q is
I don't know as well what match Q
actually does I mean same queue is a
well understood thing for comparing
Expressions I I don't know what match
queue does with numerical precision and
things like this
but I don't know
which is kind of embarrassing after all
these years it's never come up okay
magic has never has never come up as a
thing trying to match
uh approximate numbers for me I don't
think ever Chris and I definitely
discuss saying Q versus magical and we
decided that we might as well support
patterns so we might as well use match Q
I think
too much Freedom that they don't need I
mean you could support match queue as
well you could support all three
we could I think that makes more sense
because I think it's it's um now the
question okay so let's walk through what
the issues are okay issue one is it held
or is it not it's you too
how do you do the comparison is it is it
same cue match queue whatever
okay issue three what Transformations
can be run either a single one or
multiple ones on either the full
you know there's no points in running a
transformational same queue because the
same queue is already blown up by the
time transformation happens exactly but
there is a point in potentially having
you know F of blah same Q to F of blah
right yeah we'd have to do the
transformation that way but then thank
you right but but okay so
let's just walk through I mean did I get
all of the options here all of the
different cases
or in the other more cases right well we
have the tolerance which we can discuss
yeah no I know but that's part of the
that's something that will be fed into
the comparison function like does match
Q take a tolerance you can look it up I
don't know
oh I don't think so now well that's
complicated and weird I don't know why
it doesn't I mean yeah I don't know why
it doesn't I think it's Firearms so
options
there is no there is no tolerance in
match Cube now yeah but does it use same
Q or equal for its way of comparing
numbers
I bet it is the same queue
doesn't the same queue have a tolerance
um
maybe some uh well why don't we just
look it up bring the documentation up
yeah
it has the same test I think I don't
know if it has a
tolerance
oh it's very rocks as well yeah
oh no it doesn't even have same test
does it
no it doesn't okay
yeah it's
yeah it's fair because it works on rules
so
yeah
um
okay
so did I capture all the major reasons
yes you captured the major issue as well
yes okay all right so let's go through
these then
all right
I'm not
keen on the way you've done this with
the sub options for methods and so on
to me
I mean isn't assessment function doesn't
it usually have a second argument which
is the assessment method yes which can
be inferred and that's what's happened
here but it's the same as putting math
expression
we definitely considered instead of
having this method value having a math
match and a math equal and a math same
well I think that is way too complicated
for most values is I thought so too I
thought yeah having having this with
heuristics that usually get right is is
math expression is that second argument
annotatable do you have other things
where there's like a list there or not
well it can be a full Association where
that becomes a thing that's comparison
method
um
uh element-wise assessment goes to True
where you know it treats a list as a
bunch of answers
um
I don't know we can look at that you can
specify a custom comparator or how to
combine the scores when you have
multiple Parts yeah okay I remember some
of this stuff right okay so go back then
to the the other
go back to this case okay
so
and this is perhaps a Bradley question
if you just look at the math hierarchy
so to speak and you know first grade
third grade fifth grade I don't know
what
right
is there a way in which the equivalence
of math expressions gets ever
looser so to speak
I mean
you know four over six is not the same
as two over three when you're learning
fractions correct
but later on nobody really cares I mean
somebody would say somebody might say
points off because you gave four over
six and the answer to your integral
other than two over three would they say
points off for that or would they not
I I feel like at like the calculus or
the university level you you stop
getting points off for things like that
um I don't know if AP calc in particular
would mark off probably they would mark
off for for things like that okay fine
but then we've got some waypoints like
the AP Calculus rubric like you know we
got these various rubrics
seems to me that's what we should be
concentrating on if there are rubrics
for for this
you know have a version of math
expression that says you know math
expression AP calculus or something
comparison method Arrow AP Calculus
comparison method Arrow uh you know I
don't know basic algebra or something I
don't know or some class name or
something like that
because each one of these things there's
going to be a lot of complicated stuff
of whether uh you know you can consider
right and I thought we would have a
bunch of
things as you know just here AP calculus
within math expression as opposed to a
different comparison method
possibly yes and it also depends on the
the problem type right it's
uh you know a lot of the problems are
uh you know write this in a particular
form in which case the expected form is
uh very strict right if it's a a form of
a line equation or a form of you know
mixed number of a fraction versus a
improper fraction uh things like that
um what is a Linux but did you say line
expression like uh point slope for form
of a line uh whereas y equals MX plus B
versus the amazing thing is the way that
the the the the
um the jargon of all these different
forms has evolved over the last 50 years
or something anyway that's just my
amusement but but um uh
but then
let's say you're looking for the the
Point what did you say the line form of
a thing yeah point-slope form of a line
or standard form of line okay point
slope form of a line so let's say you're
looking for the answer is uh you know
4.5 4 comma two seven or something and
that's the thing you're looking for
right
or is it just it's just a pair of
coefficients
I'm sure it's a point which means which
means an actual x y coordinate I would
say so right point slope form of a line
is is that the line equation the Y
equals MX plus b that particular
equation okay
uh all right yeah
fine but but my point is here
that
so if somebody said you know U equals
five V plus 3 plus 3 that that would be
an a no right
you don't get to do that is that correct
you couldn't use any variables other
than X and Y true or not true
I think sometimes true but
uh the problem statement would typically
be you know uh use X and Y or use u and
v as the variables
okay but I mean
basically the issue here is
there's a lot of kind of content
knowledge
in
oh it's an indefinite integral but you
you know like for example okay so here's
an example for an integral okay it's a
magic function
well actually it's just sine squared x
but I give it as a major G function
am I right am I wrong
it's mathematically equal
to to most calculus teachers the major G
function is not considered the right
answer
but why not in our in our formalism so
to speak
probably full simplify would say it's
it's equal to sine squared x
are making sense
you know it's like okay I mean many many
integrals can be done very very
mechanically in terms of mergy functions
yeah right when I used to be in the
business of doing of doing um
integrals I don't know whether I ever
test type things after I was really
quite young so I never had the
opportunity to to hand in a a um uh you
know a here's the answer it's Emoji
function I didn't know about magic
functions the hypergeometric functions
what I would have said in those days
um and you know it's kind of like so I
never did the experimental test so to
speak
but it's certainly exotic and you know
but the whole point is those things are
deeply mechanical so you need to know a
lot less to say the answer is this is a
major G function then you need to
understand how to you know translate it
into signs of cosine and so on
um
Okay so
my question is if we were to take
various rubrics for things
AP Calculus there's nothing else how
many of these are there do you think
badly
oh gosh
um
I mean the the College Board stuff is
probably the best one for the US
um I can't really speak to the okay who
knows what the GAO cow does I you know
we don't somebody probably knows
but I know that AP like grading
heuristics specifically mentioned things
like uh you know uh
radicals in the denominator of a
fraction and things like that so
um
okay so we would have a fighting chance
of being able to
I mean to me one of the things that's
complicated here and that we could
potentially handle well is well you've
got the right answer but not in the
right form
and I we have a way of specifying sort
of partial credit don't we we do we do
right now the assessment result object
always has a Boolean correct value but
it also has a score value that can be
anything and you can pass back an
explanation that's presented to these
all right but but I mean to me this is a
really you know we've got to ask
Educators and things what what they need
because I I don't know I mean right you
know for me the hypergeometric function
is the right answer as far as I'm
concerned it's not the best answer but
it's a you know
um
now in terms of of um
let me think for a second uh right I
mean choice
okay we may be able to have some El
Cheapo things I think they will not be
widely understood I think the only way
to do this for real is a you know an
actual content specific curated rubric
XYZ type method
and I would even I I think isn't the
term rubric a fairly common one for
describing
you know what's considered acceptable
and what's not that goes beyond the just
right answer wrong answer is that is
that not correct
somebody
educating education oriented respond to
that badly perhaps
I don't know what the official term is
okay we should find that out we have
plenty of people in the company who know
this stuff
um I think you guys should do a separate
a meeting with some of the folks like
Alec in the UK and all kinds of people
who know about this stuff I do not
okay um we can set that up right over
right I mean and then and then what you
want to ask is okay so for what you're
doing right now
uh
I mean I have no idea what what
heuristics is math expression using to
determine equality
right but I mean by default it's you
know inactivating local symbols and
sending it to equal
just to equal not to full simplify no
that if you you can do Transformations
goes to full simplify if you want that
people are not going to understand that
but you know one of these named methods
we have is simplify that it will do that
foreign
it's just a convenience on top of equal
because we have a Doc Page you want full
simplify I think by the time you go I
don't know in some cases full simplify
is going to blow up your exercise right
if you say is sine 2x the same as 2 sine
X cos cos x
people you know
I mean this is why the only way to do
this in my opinion is I mean okay one
thing we do not have
is all the possible mathematical
Transformations that we can do we don't
have a big list of them I I tried that
actually in SNP in 1980 people didn't
find it very useful maybe the world's
changed and they'd find it more useful
today of just saying these are all the
Transformations you know number them
label them you know which ones do you
want to apply
uh
okay
so but Bradley do you want to comment
some more on what you think should be
done here
um
most of my familiarity with this stuff
is through working on problem generator
one thing that we did there that I'm not
seeing here is a atomic test and and not
not capital a atom Q or anything but we
we check to make sure that there weren't
uh you know symbols like integrate or my
RG or
things like that so
um
right right that's a good right right
okay you know what the basic bottom line
here is this is going to be a big
heuristic mess
and we shouldn't pretend otherwise and
we should provide content dependent
you know names here so I don't even
think
um
I don't even think math expression is
the right concept for a comparison
method it's not a comparison method
it's a type of thing
I mean you know mathematical equality
would be the right thing to call it if
that's what we were dealing with
which is what you've said math
equivalence over there yeah the method
option I mean comparison method
math equivalence is a reasonable thing
to say
and I mean other comparison methods we
have if we want consistent grammar 10 or
mostly
nouns we have things like quantity and
geoposition and
I see
um okay well fine fair enough
but then I think math expression should
mean we try as hard as we can to find
out if these things are equal which
means we use full simplify we do all
these kinds of things
and everything below that is some kind
of rubric for some particular
educational level and so on
okay
I mean treatment defaults is certainly
hard if you think the default should be
heavier weight
I don't have no I think the default
should be
is the thing mathematically equal
I I think I mean
because I don't really see other than
you know it then comes down to specific
operations you know commutativity do we
include associativity
you know commutativity two plus X is the
same as X plus two okay we believe that
right right now what about associativity
you got extra friends in there
great
you know I I don't know I mean for some
you know four over six versus two over
three
you know are they equivalents are they
not
right Community we you know for the case
for the match method we Chris did work
uh to make that work for things that are
orderless expressions yeah well right
uh maybe I mean I it's a total mess
right I mean to me it's like is it
mathematically equal
which means we try as hard as we can you
know you're doing a class and control
theory or something and an unevaluated
integral will be considered okay perhaps
right get what I'm saying right
um here's the convex optimization
problem I'm done yeah thanks
and um
you know I think
and I think for
you know it's calling it math expression
I mean maybe we should say
maybe we should break that more into
algebraic expression because I can see
not wanting to do Transformations I
think it is a more advanced kind of math
where you're doing you know let's say it
says algebraic expression words
algebraic equivalents
okay okay that means you're doing
uh
I'm not sure if it's a comparison of pre
expression yeah
uh equivalence you said no I said I mean
if you're using nouns you've got to say
okay okay
that means you're not allowed to do sine
2x goes to 2 sine X cos x
right that just means
you know I mean conceivably there's an
arithmetic expression algebraic
expression math expression
okay an arithmetic expression
what does it do it doesn't do
yeah algebraic expression would take
sine sine X squared minus one it's the
same as x minus One X plus one
arithmetic expression
I don't know I mean I think it would
inactivate everything except a small
family of symbols and then feed it to
equal and wrap it in simplify or full
simplify
Bradley what do you think about this
foreign
I think this is the right track
um again with problem generator we had
we have specific kind of answer checking
uh parameters four different problems
right so you know the entire universe of
problems coming in yeah essentially we
know right okay what what is the what
are the options there how many are there
uh dozens
um and and some of them rely on each
other right uh I mean there's there's
problems that expect an integer that's
easy that's simple there's ones that
expect a particular form of the fraction
so there's two or three of those
um there's ones that expect uh a
particular form of a polynomial like the
factored form or the fully expanded form
um which are you know different
heuristics for for each of these uh so
there's there's lots of them but it's
very problem specific and I don't know
how to generalize that until you get to
like the algebra level or the the
calculus level
well the problem-specific ones remember
these are specific problems that we have
here so people can you know if they know
it's supposed to be two-thirds they can
just say it's supposed to be two-thirds
they don't need to do any fancy
you know but the problem generation is
different because it generates problems
so it doesn't know
it doesn't know what the answer you get
what I'm saying whereas here the teacher
can figure out oh I think the answer is
blah and put that in
right
so I think the problem generation is a
more extreme case
um
look I think you guys need to go back to
talk about math content here
I I think
you know as an my
external view would be
that arithmetic algebra math
are perhaps reasonable levels where math
means you know you're calculus and above
I think you're going to need specific
things
for things like indefinite integrals
where it can differ by a constant right
yes
so you think this differentiation
between
yeah arithmetic and algebra should
happen at the comparison method level
and not the method option level yeah
I think so because people really want
that I mean they know they're teaching
algebra class and you know it's a big
thing they don't want to be filling in a
method option every single time for
everything that seems that seems
reasonable to me the the line there is
blurry about what should be in
comparison I agree but I think in the
first approximation
you know if you are teaching a
particular course
unless you are making a very specific
point you should be able to use a
comparison method that is somehow keyed
into your course
see what I'm saying yeah that's a rule
of thumb that makes sense
right so
I you know
I think we need to iterate this you need
to go ASAP talk to a bunch of people
within the company who know about these
different courses I mean I don't know
who's done you know I know we've done a
lot of stuff matching to grade levels
and common core standards and things
like this
um whoever's been involved in that will
be a good person to ask about this
okay then I think you gotta you gotta
code up the I'm I'm gonna say pick like
five rubrics
okay
and maybe we make a rubric up that's you
know like algebra caught I don't know
what grade people do algebra and I I
have no idea fifth grade I don't know
what what grade do people do algebra
seven and third
okay I wasn't so funny if it was not
enough by two grades then okay fine
um
uh
but you know you know Define math levels
algebra calculus you know whatever
arithmetic
and have comparisons appropriate for
those levels I think and and try to have
the general case of those and then maybe
they're a special casing for people who
are you know teaching a very specific
you know class etc etc
makes sense
yes I think that this that still falls
into this framework I think all of these
things are basically still yeah yeah I
mean controlling evaluation applying
transformations
right so okay so let's just look at the
the do-it-yourself approach right so
this is the do-it-yourselfer perhaps
right
um do we want to stay on the demo or do
you want to look at the Doc Page let's
look at the documentation page okay I
see this is a new kind of documentation
page for comparison methods good uh
um where this is the the biggest one all
the other ones are pretty I think this
is wrong I'm sorry I I just think you
should break this up I think by the time
it's a math expression we just you know
kind of know what we're doing by the
time you're talking about you know equal
versus same q and so on it's not a math
expression anymore
that's a math expression we're expecting
it's an equal comparison blah blah blah
if you want something different okay I
think you want to call it a symbolic
expression or something well yeah
but I mean there are a number of these
it
it's useful to use match and apply
Transformations that are specifically
designed for mathematics
no look look okay look
there is a function which generates a
canonical form either of the left hand
side and the right hand side or of the
combined equality I don't know whether
it's useful to do it to combined
equality I don't know whether our
functions actually pay attention to that
whether full simplify basically Maps
across the two two sides
forget what I'm saying I think it does
it inside no it does the full expression
on on inequality
okay well fine but then that's so you
know so those are the two cases it seems
to me is either
you're doing I mean please check that
with somebody who really knows because I
don't think that's right
okay I don't think it looks separately
it looks at the two sides together but I
might be wrong
okay
um
um but the more common case and I don't
yeah I mean what I would do is just say
you've got an equality expression with a
double equals not same Q right just
double equals if it's math right
you can provide a function which is the
thing to bash that with to try and
resolve it
end of story
just a function you can provide for
simplify you can provide whatever you
want
just
there is a canonicalization function and
maybe that should be an actual option
can you hold or inactivate no sub
Expressions why would you do that well
otherwise students can just pass in the
the question as the answer
they could just give code
and it'll evaluate
well I mean that's what you have to do
when you say map expression you've got
to inactivate all those things
that's that's what it means to have a
certain level I mean maybe that's the
definition of map expression as opposed
to symbolic expression
maybe symbolic expression
is whatever it is with the bashing
function with the canonicalization
function there
and if you say math expression it will
deactivate it will inactivate everything
that isn't math everything that isn't
resolved math if you understand what I'm
saying
right so inactivate integrate and
activate Factor all those kinds of
things
right just don't inactivate the
mathematical functions the numeric Q you
know numeric and some other non-numeric
mathematical functions
does that make sense
I understand what you're saying I'm sure
that there are counter examples to why
that's going to fail
um but I'm not coming up with them at
the moment okay but that's my suggestion
and activate everything that isn't math
yeah there probably are examples I mean
Michael will be a good person to ask for
that
right yeah functions that you're
thinking of as mathematical functions
that you don't want to evaluate because
it would ruin the question
yeah fine whatever I mean I know they're
going to be exceptions right we're going
to give people various rubrics and just
like you know a code of laws or
something people are going to find
loopholes right but I think we want to
keep this do it yourself open framework
that we have here
I don't think I think it's too
complicated I think it's not the right
thing I think you should give a
comparison function it's either equals
or it's same queue whatever and a
canonicalization function
in fact the whole thing that could be
wrapped together it's just the
essentially assessment function which is
either full I think the only difference
between that and what we have is that we
also have the inactive pattern option
which I think you need
what is an active pattern the the the
thing that
so before before it passes it to the
test function it calls inactivate with
whatever's here
there would be a bank of those things
for math expression I I think that's I
think we can come up with a
collect yeah a collection of named yeah
but then you're going to want to vote
that you can create or inactivate those
with respect to those names
so I'm saying you could say oh but for
my particular class I want the binomial
coefficients to evaluate
right but I also think we should have
one that's just open and you can specify
things directly
but we should force people into named
classes I know that but but look they're
not going to think of which things you
have to inactivate okay they're going to
get it wrong all the time do I have to
do subtract do I have to do minus do I
have to do this do I have to do that yes
I'm not going to get it right it's quite
complicated it is yes
so I don't think we're going to get all
the classes right either right but so I
think we should just punch completely on
this and if they want some detailed and
activation thing they should just write
code to do it and they can be a function
repository entry for some specific case
of a you know class about binomial
coefficients or something and and that's
how it's going to work rather than us
trying to partially do it and have
people use inactive pattern on things
where they're going to get it wrong and
then they're going to be unhappy
I mean I I think it should either be
completely
you get to do the comparison you write
the comparison function these are not
incredibly complicated these comparison
functions I think having you know either
that or it's completely kind of we
babied you and we did it for you with uh
with you know with a named comparison
those are the things I think we should
be doing
and I think we should be clever about
the name comparisons now whether whether
those name comparisons need sub-options
I do not know that depends on
details about math education that I
don't know
makes sense
I mean what do the CBM guys do
what have they done for math expression
comparison
I don't know I don't know that they have
they they do a lot of freeform math
inputs but they do have math inputs okay
so I I think this I'm sorry but I think
you know it's what happens in these
design reviews the the you know I think
I think this didn't go quite in the
right direction I don't think you want
these weird complicated sub options I
think you either want we're just going
to do the right thing math expression
algebraic expression whatever else or
it's pure do it yourself
and I just don't believe I'm sorry I
just don't believe in these these
partial things these partial things may
be super useful for us to implement you
know algebraic expression for example
but that's on us
and
you know
I I think that's what we have to do
either people use the the you know the
the things that we've created or they
write their own and possibly we can put
in the documentation page we can put the
code that's used by our comparison
functions possibly if that if people
find that useful and then they can just
modify it take out a transformation add
a transformation and so on
does that make sense
yes okay anything else we should make
sure to cover I'm afraid this is going
to have to come back another time
so please please work with the people
who know math content stuff
we have and we've done
plenty of collaboration
okay um well I'm afraid it needs I I
think I gave you an outline unless you
violently disagree with it I think we
should wrap up here okay the other
people
Chris Stephen Schroeder Avery
have questions
no
uh I just wanted to say that probably
with the low level
development that we have done here we
can answer all these uh specific
problems so that was the point actually
to to say that having this inactive
having this transformation we can build
a specific answers for
that sounds good to me right I the point
that I'm making is I don't think this
intermediate layer is terribly useful to
users I think either the complete
do-it-yourself where they understand
they can write code or where we've given
them a fully babysat
version of I think those are the two
useful endpoints I think this
intermediate one where people look just
just to explain this you know anytime
people have to understand a new
sub-language of you know a whole nest of
options and so on that's asking a lot of
them
and it's only worth doing if it really
has really high payoff relative to they
just learned the generic wolf and
language story and you know that's where
they go okay what's the seller but we
only need to teach it to one person
we only need to teach these these yeah
uh sub options to to the llm yeah right
well it won't get them we won't get
these it's a it's a long training path
it's got to have lots of examples it's
just not worth it I mean it's going to
have a much better chance of writing the
generic code than it is writing and I
think with these sub options it's never
going to learn it it's not going to
learn I understand I I I understand what
you're saying I don't think we have to
throw away code I think very much what
we have we'll be able to use to do these
things I think we'll have less
documented in 13-3 but we'll have better
stuff when it's does get documented
right but but let's let's try and work
as quickly as we can to get a few
rubrics that we can document okay sure
yeah that makes sense experimental and
even if we find though there's a
loophole here we have to change this
Etc I mean you know I think again I
don't understand the education stuff
well enough but you know it seems like
grading is somewhat
you know it's it's somewhat subjective
at some level I mean whether
I don't know
you know in in um
uh yeah I I just think if we had to
change the rubric slightly because of a
corner case I think that's okay but I
think we should try to get these things
appropriate for different levels of
courses and I I would say there's a you
know there's a standard course sequence
by grade level right so let's make sure
we hit each of those in an appropriate
way
okay
all right good stuff okay I mean this is
going in a good direction thanks okay
bye guys bye